what do you think was going to Stalin's
mind in the 20s and the 30s
like
did he directly
like allow himself to acknowledge the
reality
of the suffering he was causing like
what does it take to be that human I I'm
almost interested
to extract lessons from that for leaders
of today
like how hard is it is it that Stalin is
evil or can you just delude yourself
gradually into where you don't have a
sense of the effect of your policies in
the populace well you're not deluding
yourself because you have around you an
entire government of people telling you
24 7 how great you are how thankful they
are for you how awesome you are you're
the best uh so that certainly going to
play into it I've asked myself that
question as well like do these people
believe their own [ __ ] and I just
and I think the receipts are uh when
Elena chachescu who's one of the four
women on the cover when she's being
taken away to be executed in 1989 she's
yelling at the soldiers how could you I
raised you like a mother so she at least
believed her own [ __ ]
um
with Stalin he was obviously extremely
intelligent uh I think it's kind of easy
for us to kind of psychologize and say
he's a sociopath he's a narcissist he's
this he's that
um but at this at a certain point like
if you're surrounded by a culture
dedicated to glorifying you and everyone
you meet is so happy to see you and oh
my God all your pronouncements are so
good and it you know what if some if you
make a decision that's wrong the people
around you it's their job to tell you
why it's not your fault it's the fault
of the Wreckers or it's the fault of you
know Hitler or whoever it is the kulaks
at a certain point the human mind wants
to believe how great it is
especially someone in that vaunted
position
but he had his love there was this one
funny I'm using the word Loosely quote
when Hitler invades Russia and he
couldn't believe it and he's just
missing an action for days because how
could Hitler betray me we had to deal
birds of a feather and he had this quote
about like we've taken Lennon's Legacy
and [ __ ] out our asses I think he was
very aware that that's no question that
he was aware that in terms of being a
philosopher or a thinker he wasn't on
Lenin's level right so that was I'm sure
played a lot into his psychology
that he'd never quite lived up to the
like everything he tried I mean there's
some sense that the collectivization
that this idea was a failure
the way he responds to the economic
policy being a failure is to lean in
and basically torture anyone who says
it's a failure and double down on the
policy
like that says something about it but it
wasn't a failure it broke the ukrainians
you don't think he believed early on
that's what it turned into but you don't
think in the very early days
there was a thought that
collectivization is the right mechanism
by which to
um enact communism I think his goal was
to break their spirit
and getting them fed was secondary right
and given the fact that they stopped
complaining because they're dead
he got what he wanted
he got a compliant population
I mean that's really interesting I
didn't
I wonder how much disagreement there is
about
because if that was the goal from the
beginning that's a different level of
evil I think that was clearly so his hit
what like I said earlier he broke with
Landon because he wanted socialism in
one country right that was his vision
right and he was also very aware that
what became the Soviet Union was
extremely diverse versus gigantic
country is the big country on Earth it's
not always gigantic you had all these
peoples these nationalities within it
that have had historical anemone and
they're not they're not gonna have
loyalty to Moscow he's a Georgian
himself this was always a big problem so
that was what he wanted to do as well is
the homogenize and have them be
standardized and I don't see how you do
that without either massive re-education
which is only going to go so far or
really just crushing people's spirits
so uh like a forced
homogeneity yeah
and the other big thing a big element of
Soviet culture and the Soviet mythology
I mean he called his name was uh he
changed his name to style and I can't
even pronounce this Georgian name jokes
really or something like that it means
Man of Steel so a large part of the and
this still remains in in Russian culture
to this day I see it in my family too
and like other Russians I know there is
this pride in ruthlessness and this kind
of like I'm so tough like nothing's
gonna affect me like yeah we're gonna
suffer but it's for a greater good or
for the long term and not to be kind of
sentimental or squeamish about things
like that was a big part of it don't
take that away from me too Michael what
are you taking everything am I wrong
I admire uh not not stoicism but that
kind of hardness uh I look forward to
myself it has nothing to do with Stalin
but not to the extent that like if some
like for example like if you see
um someone suffering oh yeah and and
that's being used as a mechanism to get
you to change your opinion you're like
they're not gonna get to me like that is
very much part of that Russian
psychology right
uh at least at that time yes I think
still largely no
I'm not going to be manipulated by
someone else is suffering a weakness
that kind of thing I think that's really
part of it to this day
I don't know I don't know how much of
his character how much of it is reality
sure sure
um
I remember I knew that I knew of someone
who was him and his fiancee were Russian
and they had this big fight she took off
the ring right and she's like you know
he's like that's it and it's just like
the way he told the story to me she's
like what do you want me to say oh don't
leave me baby I can't live without you
like that nasty cruelty I don't know man
I know I know you're so I I don't know
if there's a Russian thing that's just
that's just a people thing I don't think
that's an American thing
I think there's all kinds of flavors and
they're different by region of the way
that people are cruel to each other sure
that in America New Jersey is different
than Texas is different than California
you don't think Americans are higher
trust more kind Society than Russia even
today
the higher trust uh listen I'm not going
to so first of all I have a very complex
uh
feelings about Russia today I'm talking
about let's talk about January before
the war I'm talking about nowadays
I think it's a complex psychological
Dynamic of what trusting means I think
Russians are generally less friendly but
have more intimate
uh friendships yes I think that's true
so it's just a different it's not
different it's just one is more trusting
which is more trusted Americans
but then this would Define trusting
different because okay I'll give an
example if someone's having a party in
America and people come over yeah okay
that's fine everyone's welcome if it's
in Russia it's like who who's that who'd
you bring and there's much more of a
like let me be sure that's okay this
person's here no I may be it's there you
don't have parties I have never been in
a party and you don't come to mind thank
you fantastic it was very sad well I
love but I love but you should have
showed it by showing up Jesus man I'm a
high height from the world and I'm
afraid of social interaction and I just
lay on the ground instead and feel sorry
for myself it's not bad santa it's sad
Santa
well I can serve I can serve my
emotional energy towards this one day of
the year okay
intensely spread my joy